Many people seek love or to be in a relationships
but that involves growth which can at times be painful,
compromised and vulnerability.
Love demands that we constantly improve, be more
understanding and practice patience.
On the flip sided it also means knowing when things just
aren't working out anymore
and having the guts to leave. Confused about how you feel,
Here are 6 signs you were never in Love.
One, you move things fast with your partner.
Infatuation thrives on speed while love takes time
to develop. Relationship expert Susan Winter says
"Infatuation lives in illusion.
Love can survive reality".
When you're quick to jump in a relationship with someone, you base it off
your dreams more than whose really infront of you.
Common examples include fantasizing
about your future with them,
lusting after them, and obsessing about them
all done only after a few weeks of knowing them
Two, you expect them to be flawless, and then you get angry
or disappointed when they show you their true colors.
Do you believe in soulmates or fate?
It sounds good in theory, right? But Winter
states that infatuation needs perfection
in order to survive. When you expect your partner
to be consistently well dressed, good with their words
or impressive with their accomplishments, you're
not giving them space to be honest with you.
Love, on the other hand, is grounded.
When you love someone, you accept their imperfections,
work through the bad and enjoy the good together,
Three, you're not comfortable around them.
Okay,  who has'nt felt self conscious about saying
the wrong thing or making a bad impression? But when you truly
fall in love in someone, that's when you can let loose
and stop caring so much. Doctor Brennade Brown
research expert on vulnerability discovered that
those who have a strong sense of love and belonging
are more open to vulnerability.
Whereas those who feel disconnected with their partners
consistently build their walls up. When you don't share
your emotions and struggles, nor secrets with someone,
you haven't fully loved. Four, you become more
distant. It's normal for passion to intensify
initially only to taper
off into a steady relationship. But two people
in love will still want to be around each other frequently.
If you find yourself wanting to get away from your partner
more and more these days, cancelling dinner plans
often because you'd rather go hang out with your friends or family
or cat, then something's up.
Five, your mind is elsewhere, and soon your heart
follows too, Stephen Betchen, author of magnetic partners states that
"Partners who are in love tend to maintain a focus on their
counterparts. When you notice the little things about them,
or express concern when the two of you run into conflict,
it shows that you care for them.
But if you avoid those
tough conversations or slip away from arguments,
you also stop emphasizing their importance in your life.
Six. you've developed anxiety,
Have you been experiencing digestive problems or have trouble sleeping?
Psychologist K. Bylist Kleely and Doctor
Ann Shiba both say that
anxiety can show in this bodily function
you might have something you need to get off your chest and dread how
to break the news off to your partner. Remember, you can only
run away from the truth for so long before it catches
up to you. Forcing love when it's absent will only
the two of you. Both of you deserve to
find love elsewhere if it cannot be found in your relationship.
Where do you think you stand on your feelings?
To learn more about the signs you're falling in love,
check out our video here. Thanks for watching!